- Il faudra plus que
des souhaits, des pensées
et des prières.
Au Vatican, le pape dit prier
pour que les pleurs de la Terre
et des pauvres soient entendus.
C'est non loin de là que
les leaders des plus grandes
économies du monde tentaient
d'aplanir leurs différends
dans la lutte contre les
changements climatiques,
le Prince Charles leur rappelant
que l'avenir de l'humanité
est en jeu.
Pour s'entendre, ils ont dû
faire des compromis.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- Le Canada aurait voulu
du langage plus ferme
et plus ambitieux dans la lutte
contre les changements
climatiques avec d'autres pays
qui le voulaient aussi.
- Il n'y a pas de date
précise pour atteindre la
carboneutralité, mais le groupe
convient qu'il est primordial
d'y arriver d'ici
ou vers le milieu du siècle.
- J'aurais aimé un engagement
plus ferme pour faire comme
le Canada et se commettre
à net zéro d'ici 2050.
- Un engagement laisse quand
même penser qu'il est possible
de progresser,
selon cet environnementaliste.
EDDY PEREZ, Réseau Action Climat
- Pour que le G20 arrive
aujourd'hui à s'entendre
sur l'importance de garder
l'objectif du 1,5 à portée
de main, c'est quand même
significatif. Il était temps,
en fait.
- L'hôte du sommet avait bien
prévenu que les décision prises
auraient un impact sur le sommet
de Glasgow.
- Je pense que ce G20 a illustré
les défis qui nous attendent
à la COP26.
EMMANUEL MACRON,
président de la France
- Ce G20 a été, malgré les
tensions, malgré les divergences
qui peuvent apparaître et qui...
que les négociations
des derniers jours,
parfois des dernières heures
ont pu confirmer, a permis
de recréer de la convergence
en vue de Glasgow.
- Les pays du G20 émettent 80 %
des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre de la planète.
Les décisions prises ici
pouvaient donc propulser
ou miner la conférence sur le
climat qui s'amorce à Glasgow.
Avec des résultats
en demi-teinte,
rien n'est encore joué.
Ici Madeleine Blais-Morin,
Radio-Canada, Rome.